welcome to the heavy spoilers show i'm
your host paul and it's time to lock up
your daughters because game of thrones
house of the dragon is back i thought
this was another brilliant entry and
throughout this video we're going to be
going through some of the law easter
eggs characters and what you need to
know about the events of the show like
last week there'll be no future spoilers
about any deaths marriages or twists but
we might talk about some things that
could be coming down the line so if
you're someone who likes to go into
things as blind as possible then this
isn't the video for you if it is though
then please hit the thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe for breakdowns
on the series every week without the way
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into house of the dragon
[Music]
okay so up top quick disclaimer for the
breakdown as many of you know we get
early access to the show and it has been
said that episode 2 is where they'll
debut the titles for the series we
didn't actually get a look at them in
the early copy we were shown so we won't
be breaking it down in this video
however if it does come with one we'll
be covering it on a clip's channel which
will be linked as the pin comment on
this video anyway we start off with a
focus on several of craigs crab feeders
victims he's given crabs to thousands of
people like ryan aries mom and come the
end of the entry he's set up as one of
the main antagonists in the book he's
described as a merciless monster who is
a nightmare in the stepstones this is an
area that lies between several important
territories as shown on this map and
crab feeder disrupts most of the trade
routes for the realm by doing this come
the end of the entry we watch as lord
callus goes to damon for help and
together the pair very much set out to
take him down from the off we instantly
see how he earned the name crab veda and
the source material talks about him
stacking hundreds of captured pirates
out on the wet sands the book describes
how he not only fed them to the crabs
which we see here but it also talks
about how they drowned slowly as the
tide rolled in it's a brutal way to open
the episode and it instantly sets up why
he's so dangerous last week corliss
brought him up on the small council but
unfortunately this fell on deaf ears
becerras actually viewed crab feeder as
doing good because it disrupted the
pirate activity and this is why the lord
turns to his brother instead corliss is
head of the valerian household who are
said to be even richer than the
lannisters in the source material he is
master of ships and under his watch the
family amassed the largest navy in the
realm thus krager's carrying this out
causes major disruptions across the sea
and therefore he has to create a pact
with daemon so that they can take him
out all the crown end up offering is
compensation for the lost ships and for
the family of those who run the boats
however due to the ship flying his
banner coolest caesar is clearly showing
that crab feeder isn't holding back and
thus he decides to go above viserys's
head this has major ramifications going
forward which will likely be picked up
in the next episode now we could have
the small council and watch renera once
more working as the cup era this was
also a role that arya stark took with
tywin and similar to her this gives rey
an opportunity to listen to the biggest
problems she ends up acting on one later
in what's my favorite scene in the
season so far now the meaning starts
with this little throwaway line about
sir ryan so ryan was a strong lord
commander of the kingsguard but he was
ill for some time ryan was a loyal
member of the kingsguard and his death
left a position in which sir kristen
cole ends up filling now he was also
brought up in the main game of thrones
work when robb stark and jon snow were
playing together the former pretended to
be darren targaryen raz john said that
he was sarim nicolas arrives and talks
about how he wants to strike the
stepstones and put an end to kragus but
the council worries that this could
cause all that war one theme that
constantly pops up time and time again
throughout the series is how the seeds
of war are often planted during times of
peace this line is actually how the
chapter heir of the dragons opens and
this entire section of the book centers
around what's happening in the show it's
a statement that's very true and we see
it lace throughout every single aspect
of the story whether it's the battle
with craggis or all the families
attempting to set viserys up with their
daughters it's something that continues
to pop up time and time again now the
issue with viserys's leadership is that
he was almost too much of a pacifist and
therefore it allowed so many others to
gain footholds in the realm king jahirus
had reigned over a kingdom that was
constantly at peace and it was seen as
one of the golden times of the realm
becerras wanted to follow in his
footsteps but in doing this he ended up
not really wanting to rock the boat pun
not intended i said pun not intended now
because there were no big battles this
also meant that a lot of heirs lived
long enough to find themselves getting
viable positions to be the next in line
on our last breakdown we talked about
how there were 14 claims to the throne
before this was picked and this left a
lot of people angry and jealous that it
wasn't them this all ties back to how
the seeds of war are often planted
during times of peace and we're slowly
watching everything all fall into place
to create this gigantic civil war within
all the houses rhaenyra suggests sending
dragon riders is a show forced to
demonstrate to their enemies that
they're not weak she ends up intervening
later on at dragonstone which i'm pretty
sure is a new addition for the show and
whilst it seems like it could be a good
idea instead she's sent to pick the next
night which leads to kristen the pair
sort of get involved in a love triangle
with another character that i don't want
to spoil yet but it builds upon cole
getting her favor at the tournament last
time nice little detail here as we close
out on the council and if you look at
viserys's little finger you'll notice he
has a bandage on it not the first time
there's there's been a bad little finger
in game of thrones hey
now renera chooses knights in the same
location where cersei would like to
commission a map of westeros to be put
on the floor here we're introduced to
some knights and they have ties to the
book as i talked about in the last video
the source material is more like a
textbook rather than being an actual
story but there are certain characters i
get touched upon slightly in it and
whilst sir desmond is absent the
malicious of seaguard are brought up
they actually pledged allegiance to
rhaenys to be queen but as we know due
to her being a woman she was looked over
in favour of viserys rhaenys ends up
looking over the entire thing and due to
kristin being the only one who's fought
outside of a tony ronira selects him the
dornish marches are brought up and this
was an area in the south of westeros
that extended to the sea of dawn
mentioned several times in the book
these swamplands saw many great battles
including the one that coal emerged
victorious from kurta viserys going
through his models with alison i'm
guessing this is like the equivalent of
when you make a girl sit through every
mcu movie about once every six weeks any
that's wifey now alison is once more
wearing him with his dress to make her
look older this clearly works and at the
end of the episode becerras ends up
taking her as his wife otto's plan all
fell perfectly into place and he
basically did this because he wanted his
family to have a claim to the throne not
to spoil too much of what happens but i
kind of think it's okay to talk about
his motivations as that adds context as
to why he put her forward judah vasaris
not producing a male heir with emma he
saw alison as an opportunity to come in
get married have a son with him and so
on and so forth this would completely
remove raniera's claims as technically
viserys's son with alison would be the
next in line if the pair were to have a
boy gets very complicated and i'll not
say what comes from it but that's just
sort of going over why the marriage with
allison is a big win for otto the hand
of the king's role was way different
during these times of peace whereas game
of thrones had a new one every season
yeah they worked with their kings for a
long time a guy who preceded otto was
actually in his position for 41 years
and this marriage offers security for
him and his family now it becomes clear
in the show that the pair never talked
before this time but after their
marriage a lot of rumors started popping
up there's a character in the source
material called mushroom who's basically
a gossip and they said that allison and
veers were actually sleeping together
whilst emma was still alive they avoid
all that here though it may end up
popping up later down the line now this
brings up the black dread dragon after a
figure of it breaks i think we actually
saw a statue of this in the square last
week and shout out simon aberman on
twitter for pointing out that this is
also the same location where ned stark
became a foot shorter the black dread's
name was valerian and viz was its last
rider we actually saw him visiting its
skull last week with ronira and due to
him being unable to bond with another
beast viz never ended up getting another
dragon as we learn later on with daemon
it's tradition to place a dragon egg in
the crib with the baby and this creates
a bond between the pair that lasts their
whole life cut a decept which according
to cersei is the bomb anyway the place
is pretty much like a giant cathedral
and in here people even like candles for
the dead similar to christian traditions
yeah we see why rhaenyra feels sober
tried by the end as she says and already
they tried to marry my father off and
replace me as heir
this is of course alison and otto's plan
and ranira is confessing why she feels
so insecure whilst her closest friend
tries to enact the thing that could end
up posting her the pair have more in
common than not as they both lost their
mothers but this quest for power will
likely drive a wedge between the two
renera knows that she wasn't chosen
because she was the most favorable
candidate it was just because baylen
died and damon was a bit of it
also forgot to point out last week that
balin was the name of viserys's father
which shows how much stuck he put into
his son becoming the air go to what is
the creepiest scene i've ever seen in a
show for a long time how he watches the
valerians try and put their daughter
forward to be married to viserys you've
already got enough trouble with
teenagers and members of the royal
family i'm glad that this was just like
nah i'm not doing this if she didn't
watch the game of thrones finale because
it was past her bedtime she's too young
for you bro it's not even been six
months since emma died but the inner
circle viewed there being no male air as
a vulnerability even with rhaenyra in a
position of power many want to stick to
the male tradition and this ends up
splitting the houses now we finally see
the little finger unbandaged and it does
look like grayscale it does doesn't it
in the book they don't really touch upon
this at all so we don't know for
definite exactly what it is even though
it does look very similar what they do
talk about though is how the king is in
ill health so getting an air in place is
of the utmost importance after maggots
are applied to it we cut to otto's
reaction and you can slowly start to see
his brain overworking when the valerian
marriage is brought up now one thing i
love about this show is that all these
key families are big players in the
series however come game of thrones we
see as it's the baratheons starks and
lannisters that are on the top a
baratheon is of course king in season
one and ned you're bloody blooded i told
you not to get ahead of your selfie get
ahead of your selfie i said little
robert baratheon joker you pass
anyway ronira finds some commonality in
rhinese and the ladder was of course the
queen who never was hello i love my
little robber baratheon impression said
sir the only thing i'm good at you're
bastard now anyway radiera is similar to
her in that she was almost queen but
there's also the potential that she can
be ousted at any point by a male britney
says that some men would rather burn the
entire kingdom down than see a woman on
the throne and theorizes that viz knows
this so he'll marry and have kids in
order to keep the peace occurred to
allison and veers and adding onto this
scene from before it's clear that girls
don't really have a choice in the matter
even viz at the end says that he's
chosen who he's gonna marry rather than
proposing to allison or even asking her
we get a very interesting shot when we
cut to her thumb and can see that
there's a weird wound around it this was
also present during the model scene from
earlier and otto later confronts her
about it he asks her why she picks away
at it and it's clear that she's
wrestling with the whole situation now
we did have talks in the kevin spoiler's
office that this could end up being
linked to the potential greyscale that
the king might have might not but both
she and viz both get focused on their
fingers neither died from greyscale in
the book so this might just be a reach
or something new for the show with viz
seemingly downplaying it all now huge
shout out to modesty on twitter for
pointing out that this could also link
to dany getting sick with pale mare she
believed that targaryens were immune to
sickness and didn't think that she could
get ill however we learn that's not the
case and it could be that the family
just used to hide their illnesses away
so that the peasants wouldn't question
them due their ability to ride dragons
they viewed them as being gods and the
idea that they could get sick would just
lessen that image so viz doing this
could end up affecting her own personal
perception alison brings him his
favorite type fixed up and with his of
course being a monument to the dragon he
lost it means a lot to him now at this
point the small council is called
together by otto and we learned that
damon has stolen a dragon egg that was
due to be given to baby balin he's
bailing on everything and has gone to
dragonstone which leads to a showdown of
epic proportions now damon announces
that he's also going to marry miseria
and he also says that she's pregnant as
we know she worked in a brothel so it
might not even be his and if that's the
case it could dilute the lineage which
is a worry that pops up in the source
material it isn't as touched upon here
but maizeria worries that there's also a
target on her back this is for not only
the aforementioned reason but also
because the baby would be seen as an
heir we all saw with the baratheons what
happened there and characters like
genres and jon snow were seen as less
than because they came from the side
chicks now they changed thing well you
just sort of didn't but either way now
they change things spoiler and they
change things up from the book and in
those she was pregnant whereas here it's
just a play by damon in order to gain
power she might end up getting pregnant
down the line so we can follow what
happens in the source material but this
early on is just a play however like in
the book viz doesn't accept the marriage
and he very much wants damon to return
to his wife lady ria whilst viserys
wants to be the one who confronts him at
dragonstone instead it's otto who goes
the pair have a rivalry in the book and
last week they touched upon how damon
was the master of coin the book tells us
about how otto had him removed from this
position and he was then placed as the
commander of the city watch at the time
all the soldiers were in pretty poor
armor but damon outfitted them with
expensive defense items and he also gave
them golden cloaks this quote-unquote
changing of the god backfired on otto
massively as the entire army of 2000 men
were now extremely loyal to daemon and
we even see that they followed him to
dragonstone we end up visiting this
location later on in the episode and you
might recognize it from the main series
of game of thrones it's where stannis
predominantly operated out of and we can
also catch the dragon markings on the
wall that were present when he resided
there i love how we also see the
targaryen ship as we travel to it if you
look at the front then you'll see that
the mast has a dragon's head on it along
with the claws used for a number of
reasons
this is such a mysterious place
blanketed in fog along with whining
staircases that look like the great wall
of china the standoff here is so tense
with otto and damon's forces meeting in
the middle
we get some more tension with otto and
kristen the latter of which drops this
line perhaps my prince recalls when i
knocked him off his horse
[Applause]
very good now the last time they met was
at the tony last week which is said in
the book to be one of damon's most
humiliating moments damon announces that
he's going to marry myseria which makes
her instantly worried and after everyone
draws their swords she sees how
dangerous it is to be messing with
dangerous damon however he has some
backup that comes in the form of karaxis
love how when it opens its mouth you can
actually see the holes on the side that
allow it to breathe fire and it's not
the only dragon that shows up almost
like a shark moving through the ocean we
watch as the clouds start to shift and
cyrax flies in rhaenyra is once more
wearing the dark grey cloak that echoes
what dany had in game of thrones and
it's a great entrance that lays the
foundation for her descendant as she is
the princess of dragonstone and she
wants him to hand over the egg i love
the scene with the pair where she
challenges him to strike her down if he
still wants to be the heir the pair have
a really complicated relationship with
each other and if you want to know the
full history of damon then we have a
video breaking down his entire story
linked on the channel now he throws the
egg back and ryan era ends up placing it
in a scorching hot cauldron like how
they were kept in the main series a
miserian in the book is totally
different appearance wise to how she is
here she's described as having skin
pales milk and blond hair similar to the
targaryens however i quite like that
they changed this up and to me this was
done so that she's similar to shae from
the main series in that she too was a
lady of the night that ended up
embroiled in the royal squabbles and i
definitely think they're drawing
parallels between her and shea now viz
is still going back and forth over who
to marry much in the same way that
queens were expected to provide sons
kings were also expected to secure the
realm he's advised to marry lena but
yeah nonce who breaks the news to
rhaenyra and i love how they have the
model behind him showing how the kingdom
is always there in the background on his
mind by era seems to understand why he's
got to do what he's got to do and he
calls together the high council before
announcing his marriage to allison it's
a big blow to corliss who sees it as him
spitting on his offer of unifying their
houses and thus he turns to his brother
it also causes issues with rhaenyra and
it leads to a lot of conspiring going on
i love the mood that's said in the
meeting with corliss and damon and we
cut to fish girls littering his study as
well as the statue of a man's face
adorned in shells it very much speaks to
how the valerians are pretty much one
with the ocean and why stopping crabtv
corliss recounts the history of house
valeria and it speaks very much to how
they've struggled in comparison to the
targaryens who had dragons his family
very much crawled their way out of the
sea and he finds some commonality in
damon due to them both being overlooked
they are the second sons and in the
source material could still harboured a
lot of resentment over the fact that his
wife was looked over in place of viserys
he calls on him to step up where his
brother failed to and it's at this point
we get our first look at crabtv i really
think the character design is absolutely
captivating and we see his cracked skin
from the sun in sea water making him
look absolutely terrifying his
disfigurement completely juxtaposes the
way that daemon looks and it sets up a
lot of things for the future now i want
to talk about some spoilers in terms of
what corels does for the union with
daemon again no death spoilers or major
twists just talking about the next step
for the pair if you don't want to know
that then i appreciate you watching
until this point and hopefully i'll see
you next week on the next one anyway so
corliss is so serious about this union
that he actually makes damon the king of
the stepstones this means that in some
ways he finally got his crown and it
basically makes the entire area his he
is of course coming off the back of
being scorned by his brother who has
rejected not only him but also his lover
mazaria i think next time we'll likely
see somewhat of a ceremony showing this
going down and it will make damon's ego
even bigger than ever anyway that was
the major spoiler sorry if it's a bit of
a disappointment but as for this episode
it wasn't a disappointment did you like
how i tied those together now i don't
think it was as good as the first one
but to be honest it wasn't too far
behind it loved the bridge scene and
there was some really great dynamics in
this one that made it super interesting
it's great watching the book get brought
to life and they did a stellar job in
putting it on the screen obviously i'd
love to hear your thoughts on it so make
sure you comment below and let me know
we are in competition right now and
giving away three copies of top gun
maverick on the 15th of september and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode we pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter heavyspoilers if you want
some emails to watch then make sure you
check out our brighton of diamond which
will be linked on screen right now we go
over the characters full history and
everything you need to know about him so
definitely go head over there right
after this by the way thanks for
sticking through the video i've been
poor i'll see you next time take care
peace